there's none for God
in any prosperous nation when primal
fears are disappear the brain then gets
the sensation the medical name we gave
this pain is a flu inflammation
honey these scientists are saying we
shouldn't vaccinate the kids
[Music]
Oh bill tub is choking each other go
buh-bye lactation when his ass and me
garden sides got
formation and since his life contains no
strivings
as millions
Arsene thanks to an
has taken another make sure to bundle up
there because it's folios
[Applause]
[Music]
first ever polio vaccine
we've got
[Music]
sigh or attack run
above all else
Oh chip black is cracking the back 12
laughs team crustaceans for the first
ingly of living tree starts to lose
appreciation and if you probe is frontal
lobe
[Music]
everyone's still starving starving still
starving with a chance of flurries still
starving here in the
starving
[Music]
history's day we face Tommy
[Music]
free markets changed the note
make you one
[Music]
I really need work
[Music]
wherever
[Music]
that's how you run the global economy
[Music]